PROFESSOR: [? Diagonal ?]
arguments are elegant,
and infinite sets-- some
people think-- are romantic.
But you could legitimately ask
what is all this weird infinite
stuff doing in a course that's
math for computer science?
And the reason is that
diagonal arguments turn out
to play a fundamental role
in the theory of computing.
And what we're going
to talk about now
is the application
of diagonal arguments
to show that there
are noncomputable sets
and examine a particular one.
So let's look at the class
of infinite binary strings.
Now, we've seen that there
are an uncountable number
of infinite binary
strings, and that's
because there was
a simple bijection
between the infinite
binary strings
and the subsets of
the natural numbers--
that is the power set of n.
Let's look at the
infinite binary strings
that we might think of and
call computable strings.
And what I mean by
a computable string
is that there's simply a
procedure that will tell me
what its digits are.
So what I mean is that the
procedure applied to argument n
will return the n-th
digit of the string s.
That's the definition of what I
mean by saying s is computable.
I can compute its digits,
whichever digits are needed.
Now, we saw that there were
only a countable number
of finite binary
sequences, and I
mention that now because I
want to think about sequences
over the slightly larger
alphabet instead of 0 1,
the 256 ASCII characters.
And by the same argument, the
set of finite ASCII strings
is also countable.
You just list them in order
of length-- same argument
that we used for
the binary strings.
Now, the point of looking at
the ASCII strings-- the 256
keyboard characters--
is that every procedure
that we enter into a computer,
we type in an ASCII string.
Every procedure can be
represented by an ASCII string.
And since they're only countably
many finite ASCII strings,
it follows that there are
only countably many computable
procedures.
Now, since in order to be a
computable infinite string,
there has to be a procedure
which computes is digits,
we can immediately conclude
that there are only
countably many infinite binary
sequences that are computable--
only countably many computable
infinite binary sequences.
But I already said there
are an uncountable number
of those infinite
binary sequences.
So it has to be that there
are noncomputable sequences,
noncomputable infinite
binary strings, that exist.
So we can conclude that
as a matter of fact,
since the set of infinite
binary strings is uncountable
and the computable ones
are a countable subset,
there have to be an
uncountable number
of noncomputable infinite
binary sequences.
Most infinite binary sequences
are actually noncomputable.
OK.
That's kind of
abstract thing to know.
They're out there, and you
can't get a hold of them
computationally.
But the reasonable question to
ask is what do they look like?
And what we're going to
see is that if you consider
a sensible concrete
computational
problem of giving a
procedure, figuring out
whether it will run and
turn a value successfully
on some argument or not is
called testing the halting
property of procedures.
I want to know-- given a
procedure and argument that I
could apply it to,
does it return a value
or does something
else bad happen
and it runs forever
and returns an error?
We don't get a
satisfactory value out.
And if it does
[? satisfactorily ?] return
something, we say it halts.
And what I'm going to argue is
that the halting problem is not
decidable.
That is, there's
no procedure which
given input that
describes a procedure,
the fixed procedure can figure
out what its input is doing.
Let's look at that
in more detail.
So let's think about
string procedures
because we're thinking about
procedures being represented
by ASCII strings.
So let's think about procedures
that take a string argument.
So an example of
a procedure P, it
might be that when you apply P
to the string no, it returns 2.
When you apply it to the string
albert, it returns meyer.
When you apply it to this
string of weird symbols,
that causes an error.
And you apply it to the
sequence of characters what now,
and it actually runs forever.
These are just illustrations
of the kind of behavior
that some weird string
procedure might exhibit.
So what I want to
think about is--
suppose I have an ASCII string
s, a finite ASCII string.
That's the one that defines
this procedure P. When
I'm trying to run
P on the computer,
I'll have to type in
s in order to give
the computer the definition
of P to tell it what to do.
And I'm going to
say that s HALTS--
the string has this
property called halting
or HALTS-- if and only if this
procedure P that s describes
returns successfully
when it's applied to s.
This is where we're really
doing a diagonal argument.
We're taking the sth
object-- the procedure
that's described by s
and applying it to s.
And that's kind of going down
the diagonal of s applied
to s, where the n-th
element of the n-th row
in a pictorial
diagonal argument.
That's the idea that
we're going here.
But let's to go back
to the definition.
A string is said to HALT
if when you interpret it
as the description of a
procedure that takes a string
argument and you
apply that string
procedure to that
very same thing, s,
you successfully return.
That's the halting problem.
And what I want to argue
is that it's impossible
that there could be a procedure
Q that decided the property
HALTS of strings.
That is to say, Q applied
to a string returns
yes if s does return
successfully-- if s HALTS.
And it returns no otherwise.
Q applied to s will say
no if s runs forever
or if s has a type
error or s does
anything other than
successfully return a value.
Let's suppose, for the
sake of contradiction,
that there was
this HALTS decider.
I claim there can't be such a Q.
For the sake of contradiction,
let's assume there was one.
Then this is the trick
that I'm going to do.
I'm going to modify
Q to act as though it
was complementing the diagonal.
More precisely, this
is what I'm going
to do with Q. I'm
going to modify
Q to be another
procedure Q prime,
which just behaves a
little bit differently.
Namely, Q prime of s returns
yes when Q of s returns no,
and Q prime of s
returns nothing--
that is, it doesn't HALT--
if you Q of s returns yes.
So Q prime is like complementing
the bits on the diagonal,
but here's the
precise definition.
Q of s says no.
Q of prime of s says yes.
Q of s says yes.
s HALTS successfully.
Q prime then does not
HALT successfully.
It returns nothing at all.
Let's go crank through
the consequences
of these definitions.
So s HALTS means Q prime
of s returns nothing.
That was the way we
define Q prime of s.
Now, let's let t be
the text for Q prime.
If Q was a procedure,
then surely we
can tweak this procedure Q
to get the procedure Q prime.
So Q prime will have
a text that describes.
It'll be the ASCII string
that defines Q prime.
Let's let t be
that ASCII string.
What do we have?
Then by definition of
HALTS, t HALTS if and only
if the procedure that t
scribes-- namely Q prime
applied to t-- returns
a value successfully.
OK?
Now by definition of Q
prime however, Q prime
was the thing that on t, it
returned a value successfully
if and only if it was not
the case that t HALTS.
So if you put those two
things together-- that is,
we're looking at t HALTS if and
only if Q prime of t returns,
and Q prime of t returns a value
successfully if only if not t
HALTS-- then put
the two together,
and we have a contradiction.
t HALTS if and only
if t doesn't HALT.
And that contradiction says
that our original hypothesis
that we had a Q that would
decide the halting problem
can't be right.
It's impossible to write a
procedure that determines
of strings whether they
describe a procedure that
HALTS when applied to itself.
OK.
That at least gives us
some concrete problem
that we can say is not something
that a computer can do.
Even though it's a very
well defined clear question,
it's just not possible to get
a computing procedure that
will on an arbitrary string,
figure out the right answer.
Any program that
applied to strings
is trying to do this job, either
it will give the wrong answer.
Or if it never gives
a wrong answer,
it means it doesn't give an
answer at all on some strings.
All right.
Well, you could say that I don't
really care very much about
whether a program HALTS or not.
So let's look at
how do you apply
the same reasoning--
or more precisely,
as a corollary of the fact
that the halting problem is not
computable, let's
talk about something
that sounds closer to
a practical interest,
mainly type-checking.
So I want to think about
the type-checking problem.
And what I want to say
is that in fact, there's
no strict procedures that
type-checks procedures
perfectly.
So what I mean is
that I want to be
able to write a program
that will look at a program
text, an ASCII string that
describes a procedure,
and figure out whether that
ASCII string, if you ran it,
would cause a
run-time type error.
That's what type-checkers
are supposed to do.
They're supposed to
check your program,
figure out whether the program
will cause a run-time type
error.
If so, it reports it.
If not, it says,
this program is safe.
Other things may go
wrong, but it's not
going to commit a
run-time type error.
So let's suppose that I had
such a type checking procedure
C. So what that means is that
for program text s, C of s
returns yes if running s would
cause a run-time type error.
And C of s returns no-- the
output string no-- otherwise
if s would not cause
a run-time type error.
In other words, s is safe.
All right.
Now, what I claim is
that if you give me C--
if I have a procedure that's
this perfect type-checker-- I
can use C to build a tester
for HALTS, which we said
is impossible.
So how would I use C to
get a HALTS tester, H.
Here's how.
I'm going to tell you
how to compute H of s.
I'm describing the procedure
that this tester H carries out
on argument s.
And what it does is
given argument s,
it's going to construct
a new program that's
a small modification of s.
It's going to construct this
new program s prime that acts
like an interpreter for s.
So s is a computer
program or a procedure.
I want to know whether if you
just run it, it'll HALT or not.
I'm going to tweak it a little
bit so that s prime acts like s
but in a slightly modified way.
And here's how s prime works.
S prime is going to be an
interpreter that's simulating
step-by-step how s behaves.
But at the moment
that it discovers
that s is about to
commit a run-time type
error-- that the next
instruction that s prime
would execute in simulating s
was going to be a run-time type
error-- s prime
would just skip it.
And who knows what the
consequences of skipping it
will be, but it'll skip
it and just keep going.
OK.
If s prime in simulating program
s discovers that in fact s
returns successfully--
those that is s
HALTS-- then s prime will
purposely make a type error.
So let's think about
what that means.
Well, actually let me just wrap
up what the definition of H is.
So the way H works
is given input s,
it constructs the program
s prime and applies
the type-checker C to s prime
and returns the same value
that c does.
So what we can figure
out by these definitions
is the s HALTS-- the string
s is a cloud halting string--
if and only if
the string s prime
makes a run-time type error.
Because remember,
the interpreter,
which is what s prime
was behaving like,
was simulating what s did.
And if s was going
to HALT successfully,
s prime makes a
run-time type error.
That means that C is going
to say yes to s prime-- yes,
it has a run-time type error.
And by definition of H,
that means that H of s
says yes because H of s
constructed s prime to C. OK.
On the other hand,
if s does not HALT,
that means that something
else goes wrong with s.
It's not going to
successfully return.
Then s prime-- when it's
simulating s-- is never
going to make a run-time
type error because that's
the way s prime goes.
Whenever it detects
that there would
be about to be a run-time
type error, it skips it.
So s prime is likely to keep
running forever because it's
simulating this program
s that doesn't HALT,
but it won't make a type error.
And that means that
C of s prime is going
to say no-- no type error.
And H of s is going to say no.
And that means that when
s does not HALT, H of s
properly says no.
In other words, I've just
walked through the argument
that this procedure H that
I've described actually
is a decider for HALTS.
And that's a contradiction.
The H that I gave you would
solve the halting problem
if there was a
perfect type-checker,
and there can't be a
halting problem decider.
So there can't be a
perfect type checker.
C must make a mistake.
It can't accurately
predict run-time errors.
And that is an
example of how you
reason from this kind of
contrived halting problem
that's sort of self-referential
whether the string
procedure applied to its
own definition HALTS or not.
And we can apply it to all sorts
of questions and properties
of procedures that
we really care about.
In fact, the same
reasoning really
shows that it's not
just type-checking.
That's a kind of
arbitrary example,
but there's more or
less no perfect checker
for any kind of property
that procedure outcomes
might exhibit.
Which is why theoretical
computer scientists
interested in the
theory of computation
have great respect and
interest in diagonal arguments
because they crystallize
a whole set of absolutely
logical, intrinsic limitations
on the power of computation.